for the third time this month this was
how a Monday morning began for the
people of Kiev missiles striking north
of Ukraine's Capital heard across the
city again Russia was targeting energy
infrastructure
this video pixelated to concealed its
location
said to show an electricity worker being
rescued from the rubble of an office
building
the area north of Kiev contains
important infrastructure including a
reservoir and a hydroelectric power
station we're operating under Ukrainian
military restrictions so there are
limitations on what we can and can't
film we can't show you the precise
location of the strikes but we can say
that one of the targets was a piece of
energy infrastructure north of Kiev and
the impact is being widely felt
this building is close to one blast site
soldiers prevented us from showing it
fully
in a shop in a nearby residential area
Katarina is making do she says the power
went out with the last loud blast
shortly after 9am
it was quite scary but given that we
lived through all of it in the first
days of the war it wasn't too bad it's
calmed down but it's not ideal without
the electricity others tell us they
heard 10 explosions in all four close by
and Powerful
shaking all the house were shaking and
we don't have no electricity no water no
no news no news yes no we can't read
news because you haven't energy and
internet
in another neighborhood the initial
shock of the explosions turning to quiet
resolve for now at least this is the
Seoul water supply
Alex C is taking back a bottle for
himself and one for a friend who's had a
stroke
like so many he's bracing for a winter
war on civilian infrastructure
we'll hold on we can't influence it
Britain America can't influence it we
just have to stay positive the Russian
defense Ministry released these images
of the missile launchers declaring their
latest strikes for Success
the Armed Forces of the Russian
Federation continued strikes with
long-range High Precision a and
sea-based weapons against the military
command and energy systems of Ukraine
the goals of the strikes were achieved
all designated targets were hit
Ukraine said its air defenses shot down
45 of more than 50 cruise missiles
launched
the front lines may be to the south and
east but this Monday another reminder
that this entire nation is at War
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera Fisher Rod
north of Kiev